the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
are we ready with the concept questions
from the homework this week how do we
get different there we go I look at one
it was one thing I looked the other
again this G enter into the expression
for the undamped natural frequency and
most people said no but about a third of
you said yes so that's the if you worked
on that problem now you would already
discovered the answer you'll find that G
does not come into the expression when
you do a pendulum G is in the expression
and there's a question on the homework
about what's the difference how can you
predict when G is going to be involved
in a natural frequency expression and
when it is not so I want you to I want
you to think about that one a bit maybe
talk about it at there's still questions
about it we talked about in recitation
on Thursday Friday okay so does G enter
into the expression here I'm sure you
know the simple pendulum the natural
frequency square root of G over L for a
simple mass spring dashpot the natural
frequency is K over m whether or not
it's affected by gravity so there's
something different about these two okay
let's go on to the third one in an
experiment this system given initial
velocity observe decay in amplitude
vibration by 50 percent in 10 cycles you
can estimate the damping ratio to be
approximately what well gives little
rule of thumb I gave you last week I'll
go over it again today point 1 1 divided
by the number of cycles the decay 50
percent so if it took 10 cycles 0.1 1/10
0.01 1.1 percent damping ok next at
which of the three excitation
frequencies will a response magnitude be
greatest you've done you
you've done oscillators excited by
cosine Omega T kind of things before so
at the ratio one most people said it's
where it would be the largest why at one
anybody want to give a shot here what
happens when the you drive the system at
its natural frequency
it's called resonance we're going to
talk about that today so it's when the
frequency ratio is one that and for the
system being lightly damped that you get
the largest response finally which one
we on here well this one can all of the
kinetic energy be accounted for but by
an expression of the form AI Z Omega
squared is there any that certainly
accounts for some that's by the way I
brought this system if you have it so
there's a really simple demo but it has
all sorts of so in this case we're
talking about that motion certainly has
some I Omega squared kind of kinetic
energy but there's the center of gravity
translate as it's oscillating what's the
potential energy in the system this by
the way anytime you get an oscillation
there's an exchange energy flows from
potential to kinetic to potential
kinetic that's what oscillation is so
there has to be an exchange going on
between kinetic energy and potential
energy and if there's no losses in the
system the total energy is constant okay
so the kinetic energy certainly in the
motion but when it reaches maximum
amplitude what's its velocity when it's
right here zero so all of its energy
must be where in the potential and where
is the potential in the system pardon in
the string does not stored in this
string there's only two sources of
potential energy we talk about this
glass gravity in Springs well these
strings don't get don't stretch so
there's no spring kinetic energy
their potential energy there must be
gravitational potential energy how is it
getting how's it coming into the system
so he says when that's when it when it
turns the center of gravity has to raise
up a little bit and that's the potential
energy in the system the center of
gravity goes up and down a tiny bit so
is there any velocity in the vertical
Direction is there any kinetic energy
associated with up-and-down motion yeah
so that doesn't entirely capture it
one-half I Omega squared is it an
important amount of energy I don't know
but there is some velocity up and down I
guess my guess is that it actually isn't
important that it the answer is it does
move up and down has to or you would not
have any potential energy exchange in
the system okay next is that it okay
let's keep moving here I've got a lot of
fun things to show you today let's so
last time we talked about response to
initial conditions I'm going to finish
up with that and then go on to talking
about excitation of harmonic forces so
last time we are considering a system
like this X is measured from the zero
spring force in this case give you an
equation of motion of that sort and we
found that you could express X of T as a
I give you the exact expression X naught
square root of 1 minus Zeta squared
cosine Omega damped times time - a
little phase angle and there's a second
term here v-0 over Omega D sine Omega DT
and the whole thing times e to the minus
Zeta Omega n T so that's our response to
an initial deflection X zero or an
initial velocity V zero that's the full
kind of messy expression there's another
way of writing that which I'll show you
another way of saying is that it's an X
naught cosine Omega DT plus v-0 plus is
Zeta Omega and X naught all over Omega D
sine Omega D times T e to the minus Zeta
Omega and T the same exponent that's
this is your decaying exponential that
makes it die out and so I just
rearranged some of these things there's
no little phase angle in here now so you
have a just a cosine term this
proportional to X naught and a sine term
which has both V 0 and X naught in it
the X naught term if damping is small
this term is pretty small because it's X
naught times Zeta when you divide by
Omega D which is almost Omega n that
goes away so this term the scale of it
is Zeta Omega X naught so if this is 1
or 2 percent that's a very small number
so we used I gave you an approximation
which for
are almost all practical examples that
you might want to do make an
approximately sign here so this is just
X naught cosine Omega DT plus v-0 over
Omega D sine Omega D P e to the minus
Zeta Omega n T and this is the practical
one you can use it for any any
reasonable system has relatively low
damping even 10 or 15% damping you get
part of the transient decamps comes from
X naught cosine the other part V naught
over Omega D sine and that's for all
that's what I can remember in my head
when I'm trying to do it now the
question the thing I want to address
today is you know what's this useful for
what I'm my approach to teaching you
vibration is I want you to go away with
a few simple under practical
understandings so that you can actually
solve some vibration problems and one of
them is just knowing how knowing this
allows you to do a couple things and
we'll do a couple of examples this
morning by the way
this form this is some a cosine plus B
sine expression and I label them a and B
a and B they're both of the form a1
cosine Omega T plus b1 sine Omega T and
you can always add a sine and a cosine
at the same frequency I put just any
frequency here they just have to be the
same you can always take an expression
like that and rewrite it as some
magnitude cosine Omega t minus a phase
angle then the magnitude is just a
square root of the sum of the squares a
1 squared plus B 1 squared and the phase
angle is the tangent inverse of the sine
term over the cosine term so you can
always rewrite sine plus cosine as a
cosine Omega t minus D we use that a lot
and that will be used a lot in this
course and then of course if this whole
thing is multiplied by an e to the minus
8 Omega NT then so is this
okay okay what are these things useful
for and we derived this all for a mass
spring system is that equation
applicable to a pendulum so this
political expression is applicable to
any single degree of freedom system that
oscillates you just have to exchange a
couple things so let's think about a
simple pendulum so our the common
massless string and a bob on the end
some length L the equation of motion and
this is point a up here eyes easy with
respect to a theta double dot plus MGL
sine theta equals zero that's the
equation of motion with no damping
that's the equation of motion of the
system is it a linear differential
equation no and to do the things that we
want to be able to do in this in this
course like vibration with harmonic
inputs and so forth we need we want to
deal with linear equations so one of the
topics for today is linearization so
this is one of the simplest examples of
linearization we need a linearized
equation and we need to remember in a
couple of approximations so sine of
theta you can do a Taylor series
expansion its theta minus
cubed over three factorial + theta to
the fifth over 5 factorial + - and so
forth and cosine of theta is one minus
theta squared over two factorial plus
theta to the fourth over 4 factorial so
forth so what we say what what do we
mean when we linearize something so
linearization means that we're
essentially assuming the variable that
we're working with is small enough that
the right-hand side and adequate
approximation of this function is to
keep only up to the linear terms on the
right-hand side for sine
the term raised to the 1 power that's
the linear term this is a cubic term in
a fifth order term we're going to throw
those away and say this is close enough
for cosine it's 1 minus theta squared we
throw these away
the small angle approximation for cosine
is it's equal to 1 okay so that's really
sets the simplest example of
linearization of a of a nonlinear term
so when you linearize this equation of
motion we end up with i ZZ with respect
to a theta double dot plus MGL theta
equals zero and we get our familiar
natural frequency for a bob has square
root of G over L so we need
linearization to be able to do pendulum
problems
okay and maybe let's do an example here
I've got a pendulum that will do an
experiment with this morning but you
know 30 degrees is about out like that
all right
17 degrees is about like that that's
quite a bit of angle is that small in
the sense that I'm linearizing this
equation so 17 degrees happens to be
I'll do use this and it's actually 17
point 2 degrees equals zero point 3
radians sine of 0.3 is 0.295 5 and if we
fill out look at these terms the lead
term here is 0.3 plug in the point 3
minus and the second term when you fill
it when you cube 0.3 and divide it by 6
the second term is minus my number here
0 0 4 5 and if you subtract that from
this you get exactly this so to 4
decimal places you only need 2 terms in
this series to get exactly the right
answer this thing out here this fifth
order term is really tiny
but the approximation if we say ok let's
skip this we're saying that 0.3 is
approximately 0.2 9 5 5 pretty close so
up destino 17 degrees 0.3 radians that's
a great approximation
so it's a little high by about I think
it's about one one-and-a-half percent
high so for pretty large angles for
pendulum the link that simple
linearization works just fine okay once
we get it linearized that equation of
motion is of exactly the same form as
the one up there we don't have any
damping in it we could add some damping
you could put a damping in here call it
with a torsional damper C T theta dot
and now that equation is exactly the
same form as the linear oscillator
linear meaning translational oscillator
has an inertia term a damping term a
stiffness term it's a second order
linear differential equation homogeneous
linear differential equation nothing on
the right-hand side because they're
exactly the same form than these
solution for decay transient decay from
initial conditions takes on exactly the
same form except it as an initial angle
theta 0 and I'll use the approximation
here cosine Omega DT plus theta 0 dot
the initial velocity over Omega D sine
Omega DT all times e to the minus Zeta
Omega n T so that's the exact same
transient decay equation but now cast in
angular terms
and if you wanted to express it as a
cosine Omega t minus V then the a would
be this squared plus this squared square
root and the fee would be a similar
calculation as we have up there
somewhere
here just the B term over the a term
tangent inverse all right what's it good
for
so I use this this equation gets used
quite a lot as some practical uses
I'll show you let's do an example a
little more complicated pendulum my
stick maybe center mass there a eyes
easy with respect to a we'll call it ml
cubed over three for a slender rod and
now what I want to do is I have coming
along here a mass a bullet as mass M as
velocity V I for initial here and that's
its linear momentum P initial and it's
going to hit this stick and embed in it
so you've done this problem before yeah
pardon M L cubed over three that's
that's a ml to ml good I don't know
where I was thinking cubed this morning
ml squared over three good set good
catch there okay so we have it it's mass
moment of inertia this is a pendulum
this bullets going to come along so this
is exactly what I've got here and get it
in the picture
yeah so it's initially at rest come
along and this paper is clip here it
represents the bullet sorry zooming
along hits this thing sticks to it and
when it hits it it does that so then
this thing after it hits swings back and
forth so what's the response of this
system to being hit by the bullet
well I claim you can do it entirely by
evaluating response to initial
conditions but we need to use one
conservation law to get there so what's
conserved on impact is linear momentum
conserved on impact how many think yes
linear momentum conserved how many think
angular momentum is conserved hmm good
you guys have learn something too this
month this year that's great why is
linear momentum not conserved because
are there any possible other external
forces on the system at the pin joint
you can have reaction forces here and
there you have no control of them but
the moments about this point
are there any external moments about
that point during the impact no their
reaction forces but there's no moment
arm so there's no moments so you can use
conservation of angular momentum so h1
I'll call it here with respect to a is
just R cross P I and the day R is the
length in the I direction P's in the J
directions of the momentum is in the K
so this should be M V initial times L
and its direction is in the K hat
direction so that's the initial angular
momentum of the system with respect to
this this has no initial angular
momentum because it's motionless and
since angular momentum is conserved and
h2o
respect to a has got to be equal to h1
with respect to a and that will then be
i ZZ with respect to a theta dot right
but i need to account for the mass this
thing so the total mass moment of
inertia with respect to a as i ZZ with
respect to a plus m1 now i've got the
total mass moment of inertia with
respect to this point that of the stick
plus that of the initial mass that i've
stuck on there and this must be equal to
theta dot and i put a knot down here
because I'm looking for my equivalent
initial condition and this then is M V
initial times L and I solve for theta
dot 0 and that looks like M V initial L
over as easy a plus ml squared and
everything on the right hand side you
know you know the initial velocity and
mass of the bullet the length of the
distance from the pivot mass moment of
inertia and the additional mass mobile
know sure these are all numbers you plug
in and you get a value for this and once
you have a value for this you can use
that in this problem what's fada is zero
the initial angular deflection at time T
0 plus right after the bullets hit it
and Y has and it hasn't moved because it
hasn't had time to move yet when I takes
a bullet at some velocity it takes
finite time to get a deflection so
there's zero initial angular deflection
but you get a step-up in initial angular
velocity and
the only response of this system is
theta T is theta zero dot over Omega D
sine Omega DT so what's Omega D remember
I didn't define a few things here in
this case this is CT over to i ZZ a plus
little ml squared we have to deal with
all the quantities after the collision
two times Omega and that's the damping
ratio for this torsional pendulum to
this pendulum it's the damping constant
two times the mass the inertial quantity
times Omega n for a trip for a
translational system at C over two M
Omega n for a wrote a for a pendulum
system it's the torsional damping over
two times the mass moment of inertia
times Omega N and Omega n well like four
is going to and to calculate the natural
frequency
it's just mg L divided by i ZZ plus this
and be able to write that down
so always for a simple single degree
freedom oscillator you want the undamped
natural frequency ignore the damping
term take the stiffness term coefficient
here and divide it by the inertial
coefficient but we care about the
natural frequency after the impact so
this is going to be ah
trouble is here I don't know for this
system I haven't worked out yet what
this term looks like what is it this was
this this result right here is for the
simple Bob for this stick it's mg L over
2 plus the little M times L a little
more messy so M G L over 2 plus little m
L that'll be they come from the
potential energy in the system all over
eyes easy a plus ml squared so you get
your natural frequency out of that
expression okay so you know we've talked
you do this problem sometimes before you
and when you do say somebody asks you
how high does it swing and so forth we
can do it by conservation of energy etc
but now you have actual the exact
expression for the time history of the
thing after it after the impact
including effects of damping and if you
were to draw the result of this function
of theta as a function of time this one
starts with no initial displacement but
a velocity and does this
that's your exponential decay envelope
and this is time okay know what yeah
excuse me why this one excuse me
forgot the G I mean it accounts for the
restoring moment the addition a little
bit of restoring moment that you get
from having added the mass of this thing
to it right so it has about self mg L
sine theta and we linearize it too so
it's M G L theta and those two terms
would add together so you just have a
second term here that it looks like
empty has mg L like behavior okay the
most how I am most often personally make
use of expressions like this or the one
for translation is because
experimentally if I'm trying to predict
the vibration behavior of a system one
of the things you want to know is the
damping and one of the simplest ways to
measure damping is to give a system an
initial deflection or initial velocity
and measure its decay and from its decay
calculate the damping so the last time I
gave you an expression for doing that
and that was a damping ratio 1 over 2pi
times the number of cycles that you
count that you watch it times the
natural log of X of T over X of T plus n
periods of vibration that's called this
has a name it's called the logarithmic
decrement this thing let's go in here
somebody says log decrement that's where
they're referring to this expression and
let's comment about this in this
expression X of T must be zero mean if
this if you're measurement we have X of
T here or theta of T they must be zero
mean it must also be oscillations around
zero or you have to have subtracted the
mean to get it there because if this is
displaced and it's oscillating around
some offset then this calculation to get
really messed up it's got an offset plus
an offset here plus an offset there it
means it's totally meaningless so you
must remove the mean value from any time
history that you go to do this now
there's an so there's an easier way the
same expression and this is in fact the
way I use this I'll plot out like you
know just you know your data acquisition
grabs it plots it for you I take this
value from here to here and this is my
peak to peak amplitude and then I go out
end cycles later and find the peak to
peak amplitude and so this is perfectly
this is just the same as 1 over 2 pi n
but now you do
natural log of X peak peak at T over X
peak to peak at T plus n periods and
that that now peak to peak measurement
you totally ignore the mean doesn't
matter where you are you want to here to
here here to here plug it in there and
you're done
ok so let's I got one two three four
let's let n equal four
and let's assume this expression here
and it 1 over 2 pi times 4 and let's
assume that in these 4 periods from
that's one period 2 3 4 and getting out
here to this fourth four periods away
that this is one fifth the initial so
this would be the natural log of 5 so 1
over 2 pi times 4 natural log of 5 and
you run the numbers you get zero point
zero 6 4 or what we call 6.4%
damping that's how you do that's that's
the way you do calculation like that now
I gave you a quick rule of thumb for
estimating damping and this is what I
can't work I don't do logs in my head
but I can do damping estimates without
that because I know that Zeta is also I
just plug in some numbers here and run
them all in advance is point 1 1 divided
by the number of cycles to decay 50% so
we're going to do an experiment
and I guess it can be seen as camera so
here's my pendulum and I have Tron this
is my initial amplitude and this is
about half so if I take this thing over
here like that and let go and count the
cycles that it takes to decay halfway we
can do this experiment so let's do it
carefully I'll line it up like that and
you're going to help me tell you count
how many cycles it takes till it gets to
here so 1 2 3 or 5 6 7 8 about 8 cycles
so it decayed halfway and 8 cycles so
Zeta is approximately point 1 1 over 8 1
& a half percent 1 point 4 percent
something like that okay perfectly good
estimate of damping now I've got a
stopwatch here
I'm going to do this experiment again I
want you to count you're doing the
counting and I going to say start I want
you to count cycles until I say stop
I'll probably stop on ten to make the
calculation easy so you quietly to
yourself count the number of cycles from
the time I release it until the time I
stop come back here
okay so this time the backdrop doesn't
matter we're just I just want you to
count cycles and I'll start I'll let it
get going and when it comes back to me
it's what I'm going to start the
stopwatch to that heart I'm doing both
at the same time so start
how many cycles so I got 17.8 four for
10 so 10 4/10 is 1.78 4 cycles seconds
per cycle can't write like that 1.78 4
seconds per cycle the frequency would be
1 over that right thing you have to be
careful about when you're counting
cycles is if I start here that's 0 1 2
a very common human mistake is when you
accountant something like this to say 1
when you start and then you're going to
be off by one count follow me if I start
0 1 2 so I start the clock on 0 but the
first cycle isn't completed 2 one whole
cycle later so be careful how you count
okay
now we're going to shift gears and take
on a new topic and that's the response
to a harmonic input some cosine Omega T
excitation yeah what is omega D so
that's called it's the damped natural
frequency it's how it's referred to it
is the frequency you observe when you do
an experiment like we just did the
actual oscillation frequency when it's
responding to initial conditions is
slightly different from the undamped but
if you have light damping if you have
even 10% damping point 1 squared is 0.01
that's 0.99 square root is 0.99 to 5 so
you're only off by 1/2 this is there
only half a percent difference
so for lightly damped systems for all
intents and purposes mega N and mega D
are almost exactly the same ok we now
want to think about we have a linear
system putting a force into it that
looks like some F naught cosine Omega T
and out of that system we measure a
response X of T and inside this box here
is my system transfer function it's the
mathematics it tells me I take f of T in
and predict what X of T out is so I need
to know the information that goes into
this box and of course the real system
this is just the mechanical system for
sin
measured output out this we call a
single input single output system s iso
single input single output linear system
and there's all sorts of linear systems
that you're going to study as mechanical
engineers and you already begun I'm sure
studying some of them what are the one
of the properties of a linear system is
if you put a force in f1 and measure a
response out x1 and then you try
different force f2 and your method
response out x2 what's the response if
you put them both in at the same time f1
and f2 you just add the responses to
them individually so f1 gives your x1 f2
gives you X 2 f1 plus f2 gives you X 1
plus X 2 and that's one of the
characteristics of a linear system and
we use it to we use that concept to be
able to separate there is in the
response our calculations about the
response of a system like our oscillator
here seperate its response due to
transient effects transients being
initial conditions they died out over
time is why we call them transients and
steady state effects so cosine Omega T
you can leave it running for a long long
time and pretty soon the system will
settle down to responding just to that
cosine Omega T and that we call that we
call steady state and we we use them
separately so we've done initial
conditions now we're going to look at
the steady state response of a book say
our oscillator our mass spring dashpot
to a harmonic input F naught cosine
Omega T another brief word if I have a
force F naught cosine Omega T would look
like that
and the response that I measure to start
off with might it's sitting here at zero
when you turn this on and it's going to
do some odd things initially and then
eventually settle down to some long-term
steady response the amplitude stays
constant its phase angle with respect to
the input isn't necessarily the same
there's some possibly phase shift and
that's so the two would if you're
plotting them together they won't line
up and see this messy stuff at the
beginning when you first turn this on it
jumps from here to here that force and
it gives it a kick to begin with and
this will have some response initially
due to that transient start up and this
response which is all modeled by the
response to initial conditions and it'll
die out after a while this messy stuff
what's the frequency what freaks do you
do you expect this initial you look
erratic looking stuff to be at it's
response to initial conditions what is
the model for response to initial
conditions what's the frequency of the
response to initial conditions of a
single degree freedom system we have
equation over here right
up at the top has a cosine term and a
sine term part of his response to
initial displacement part of his
response to initial velocity any of this
startup stuff can be cast as initial
conditions and the response to initial
conditions is always at the damped
natural frequency period no other
frequencies for a single degree of
freedom system so you get a behavior
that is oscillating at its natural
frequency mixed in there is response at
the excitation frequency and after a
long time the response hat is only
excitation frequency this is now out
here this is Omega in here you have
Omega and Omega D going on so this is
messy usually is an important that is
there are ways of getting the exact
solution but mostly vibration engineers
you're interested interested in the
longtime steady-state response to the
harm what we call a harmonic input okay
so we'll work a classic the classic
single degree freedom oscillator problem
excited by F naught cosine Omega T
you've done this in 1803 but now we'll
do it using engineering terminology and
look at it the way a person studying
vibration would think about this we know
the equation of motion and I'm
interested in the steady-state response
so this is X and I'll do we just write
it once like this SS steady state I'm
only interested in its after those
transients have died out and that steady
state response I know is going to be
some amplitude X naught cosine Omega t
minus some phase angle but I don't
necessarily know to begin with but
that's my input this is my output I plug
it into here and turn the crank and see
what falls out so
so you plug both of those in and you get
two you get there's going to be a little
writing intensive for a few minutes
so you plug the X naught cosine Omega T
into all of these terms the M term gives
you minus M Omega squared the K term
gives you a K and the damping term minus
C Omega sine Omega t minus V all of that
equals the right-hand side F naught
cosine Omega T so this just purely from
substitution and then gathering some
terms together so I'm going to I'm going
to divide I'm going to divide through by
K by K Phi divided through by KK divide
this give me a 1 this gives me an M over
K which is 1 over the natural frequency
squared for example and I'm going to put
this into a form that is the standard
form for discussing vibration problems
so this equation can be re-written in
this form 1 minus Omega squared over
Omega N squared cosine Omega t minus V
minus 2 Zeta Omega over Omega n sine
Omega t minus V all that's still equal F
naught cosine Omega T so this is getting
into kind of more standard form which is
1 minus Omega this now this Omega over
Omega is called the frequency ratio
we're going to see a lot of that and
I've substituted in here C Omega over K
turns out to be 2 Zeta Omega over Omega
n so this frequency ratio appears a lot
in our
see
now you need I'm going to expect you
need a couple of trig identities cosine
Omega t minus C cosine Omega T cosine V
Plus sine Omega T sine fee and sine
Omega t minus V gives you
remember my sign sine Omega T cosine V
minus cosine Omega T sine V so that's a
trig identity and you actually use quite
a bit doing vibration problems we need
them so we take these plug them in in
all these places and do quite a bit of
cranking yep yeah thank you and that
that's called that F over K is how much
the spring would move statically which
the point would move statically we'll
get it we'll need that term also okay
you do all of this now I'll call these
okay so this is see that's expression
see
can't see that probably call this D this
e so you put your plug deaynni into C
and work it through you get two
equations
you get to you break it into two parts
because one is a function of cosine
Omega T then you have another part after
the substitution that's a function of
sine Omega T and you can separate them
but there's no sign of maggoty force on
the right hand side to get zero at two
equations here how many unknowns do we
have all we know when we start this
thing is we is the input and we now have
two we have the we have unknown response
amplitude and we have an unknown phase
that we're looking for how many
equations how many unknowns two and two
so you can do a lot of grank in which I
have no intention of doing here and
solve for the amplitude of the response
and the phase
and every textbook the Williams textbook
does this there are two readings posted
on on stellar by Rao every textbook goes
through these derivations that I've just
done Nick you got a question Hardin yeah
I keep forgetting it you're right so you
got a K here and notice this equation we
throw away that for now we get rid of
this for now we have to these two
equations and two unknowns are just
algebraic equations and there's not time
dependent we can get rid of that part
so we've now reduced this to algebra and
the answer and that's the answer is
plotted up there you've probably seen it
before says that x0 is f naught over K I
get it right this time from the get-go
over a denominator which appears again
and again again in vibration mega
squared over Omega N squared squared
plus 2 Zeta Omega over Omega N squared
square root whole thing and an
expression for fee tangent inverse of 2
Zeta Omega over Omega N 1 minus Omega
squared over Omega N squared so you can
solve all that this mess over here for
these two quantities do I do you need to
remember this you're going to find that
you're going to ever going to be asked
this on a quiz not by me you're ever
going to have to use this on a quiz and
in homework absolutely so this the
takeaway is today know how to use those
response to initial condition formulas
and damping and these two so when you
plot when you plot these you get this
picture up there and we need to talk
about the properties of this remember
this Omega over Omega n is the same
called the frequency ratio just a ratio
of the excitation frequency to the
natural frequency of the system
and when they're equal for example this
ratio is 1 this whole thing in
parentheses goes to 0 this this
expression over here goes to 2 Zeta
because that's 1/2 Zeta squared square
root is just 2 Zeta at 1 Omega equals
Omega n this whole expression is F
naught over K divided by 2 Zeta for
example and that's called resonance and
that's when you're right at where that
peak goes to its maximum we need let's
talk about this expression for a moment
if you have a we have our cart our mass
spring dashpot we started here if you
apply a force a static force F naught it
will stretch the spring by an amount F
naught over K so X we'll call X static
is just F naught over K and if I want to
plot I want to
this has a name this is called this
ratio here just gives you the magnitude
of the response it goes by a variety of
name some people call it a transfer
function some people call it a frequency
response function I write it this is I
write it intentionally this way this is
I put output over input because this
this expression has units of output over
input so I just write it like this
remember myself what remind myself what
this transfer function is about the
input is force the output is
displacement this expression has units
of force force per unit displacement
if I go to here if I try to plot this
and start over if I try to plot this
it's going to be depending on the exact
value of the spring constant and the
exact value of the force every time I'll
have to get a unique plot every time I
go to do this so textbooks and engineers
you know what I don't want to have to
remember this part this is where all of
the content is in is in this denominator
and it's dimensionless so what I'd
really like to plot is X naught over X
static if I do that that is X naught
over the quantity F naught over K if I
just divide this is X static or bring
this to the side then this expression
this is just 1 over that denominator and
sometimes I think in the text of the
handout by Rao they just call this H of
Omega
it's dimensionless frequency over
frequency and that's actually what's
plotted up there the and this is called
has different names also magnification
factor dynamic amplification factor
because the ratio of X to X static if
this is the dynamic effects magnify the
response compared to the static response
so it might be this over this might be
10 it means the dynamic response is 10
times the static response okay how do
you to sum this up and we'll be getting
close to the end we want to talk just
about the properties of this how do we
use this
so in practical use you have an input
specified some force cosine Omega T you
know you have a single degree freedom
oscillator that is governed by equations
like that one and you want to predict
the response while you say X of T is
equal to the magnitude of the force
times the and you divide that by we
could do it this way the magnitude of
the force divided by K which is the
static response to get to predict X
naught we just have to take this
quantity and multiply it by F naught
over K so you know this you better know
that about your system and you multiply
it by this quantity magnitude of H of
Omega and the whole the time dependent
part is x cosine Omega t minus the phase
angle and the phase angle you get either
off the plot or from the I written it
down haven't written the phase angle
down yet
it's kind of a messy expression - that's
where we plot it - Zeta Omega over Omega
n all over one minus Omega squared over
Omega N squared but by knowing just this
plot what you just put in every text
book about vibration in the world by
knowing this transfer magnification
factor calculating the static response
multiplying the two together you have
the amplitude of the response and it's
time dependence is cosine Omega T - a
phase angle and I've got a little
example here actually rather than the
example I got all the trouble of setting
this up
all right this is just a beam where's my
other little beam and a beam is just a
spring put a mass on the end this is
basically a single degree freedom system
it has a natural frequency the beam has
a certain stiffness okay and now I'm
what in this case we're interested in
response to some harmonic input so
anybody of you any of you know what a
squiggle pin is this is a kid's toy yeah
so all throughout the term we've studied
rotating masses quite a bit right this
thing has a rotating mass so you can see
in the anime when you leave today and
come down take a look that's a little
rotating mass it's actually a pin with
the kids toy shakes like crazy and now
we need the lights down and it happens
that the so I've got a strobe light here
and I kind of preset the frequency so
it's very close to the frequency of
vibration of this beam so this there's a
rotating mass in this pin going around
and around and it puts a force into the
system that looks like F naught cosine
Omega T in the vertical direction also
does it in horizontal but vertical is
our response direction
so it's putting in a force and I have
set the length of this of this beam so
that the natural frequency of this beam
with is mass on the end is exactly or
very close to being the frequency of the
excitation so this end I have the flash
rate is slightly different than the
vibration rate so you see it illuminated
at many positions as it goes through the
cycle so you see it going up and down so
if I mismatch it quite a bit then you
see it go and you actually if you look
at the very right end you can see a
white thing going around going up and
down that's the mask you can actually
see the mask in the very end of the
right there you can see something going
around and around there that's the
rotating mass so the beam is going up
and down and I've got this this
vibration frequency of that mask on
round and round
to the natural frequency of the beam of
the mass on hand now if I let's move in
quite a bit I'm going to loosen my clamp
and I change the length of the beam I've
shortened it
and now the it's still moving up and
down but not as much because the
frequency of vibration of the eccentric
mass is no longer close to the natural
frequency of the system so where are
what in fact I've made the natural
frequency of the system you're going to
bring the lights back up I've made the
natural frequency of the system by
making the beam shorter I've made it
stiffer so the natural frequency has
gone up the frequency of the rotation of
the eccentric mass estate about the same
so what's happened to that frequency
ratio Omega over Omega n so less than 1
or greater than 1 so the mega n has gone
up Omega stayed the same
you're now less you're the frequency
ratio when you shorten this beam is less
than 1 and the properties of the Magnus
transfer function we call it so and
where this magnification factor looks
like this when we're exciting it right
at 1 this is Omega over Omega N you
write at resonance when you excite it at
a frequency ratio less than 1 you start
dropping off this back side and the
response goes down and we could do and
if you excited at frequencies much
greater than the natural frequency end
up way out here and I can do that too
so how much you think it will vibrate
now a lot little
hardly whoops oh I've brought it out so
much you can't see it hardly moving at
all and that's because in terms of this
this terminology of magnification
factors transfer functions this is a
plot of X over X static it goes to right
here when you go to zero frequency you
are at static so the response if the
response at very very low frequencies it
goes to being the same as the static
frequency so on this plot it goes to one
at resonance you put in one here this
goes to zero that becomes a 1 2 Zeta
squared this height here is 1 over 2
Zeta that's so the dynamic amplification
at resonance is just 1 over 2 times the
damping ratio you have 1% damping twice
that is o 2 1 over o 2 is 50 so if you
only had 1% damping the dynamic
amplification amount that this vibrates
greater than its static response is a
factor of 50 greater but then as you go
higher in this Omega over Omega N and
you get way out here and you get almost
no vibration at all and that's what's
happened when I've lengthened this okay
sitting okay that's this your
introduction to linear systems in this
case a single degree of freedom system
that vibrates an oscillator we're
talking about steady-state response not
the part of the solution the
mathematical solution to initial
conditions so all of this has been about
steady-state response of our simple
oscillator to what we call a harmonic in
input F naught cosine Omega T and what
so what's important that you need to
remember and be able to use this concept
here you know this idea of a transfer
function that's really important you
might want to remember it though as this
dimensionless quantity x over X static
just remember the shape of this transfer
function magnitude of the amplification
1 over 2 Zeta at resonance you know goes
to 1 at low frequency the high frequency
it gets drops away off next time we're
going to talk pick up the topic of what
we call a vibration isolation the
practical thing to know as engineers is
is when you have a significant vibration
problem like in a lab and you're looking
through your microscope and the floor
vibration is causing trouble with your
microscope and you can't move the subway
what can you do to solve that problem
well you might be able what if you put
some kind of a flexible pad under the
microscope you might be able to reduce
the vibration of the microscope ok
things like that that's the part that is
the topic of vibration isolation so
we're going to get into that next time
Thanks
you